this is the backdrop to the Munich
Security Conference a brutal war that's
been raging for five years killing
hundreds of thousands of people and
displacing millions it's a huge
destabilizing force the leaders here
have agreed they want to end the
conflict in Syria but it was mutual
recriminations rather than any concrete
steps to do that that took center stage
in Munich today rush i responded angrily
to french accusations that it was
bombing civilians in the country Prime
Minister Dmitry Medvedev also lashed out
at NATO nature's policy with regard to
Russia remains and friendly and opaque
one could go as far as to say that we
sled back to a new code Estonian
President Thomas Hendrick ill vezz told
DW he didn't believe the Russians when
they denied hitting civilians in Syria
clearly they want to maintain a sodden
power and given all of the evidence that
they are bombing civilians I mean who
else who else is bombing Aleppo then
it's very hard to really take seriously
statements like that and of course NATO
has enough evidence of what is going on
that we really cannot take statements
like that seriously if there's one thing
leaders at the Munich Security
Conference can't agree on its that these
are especially testing times for global
security but that is pretty much where
the consensus stopped another symmetry
met